one more talk before we break for lunch
with another very intriguing topic and
evolution of Playa that's going to be a
mismatch out there
my name is John and unlike the other
speakers today I'm not a scientist I'm
an artist and I run this animation
studio called stated clearly and what I
do is I work with scientists and
educators and they make animations that
teach things like genetics we have this
animation of what is DNA and how does it
work what is the evidence for evolution
can science explain the origin of life
and we take these complex scientific
concepts simplify them and put them into
these videos that you know middle school
and high school students can understand
and you can use them in classrooms and
lectures and assignments for the past
about last summer I said what were these
two guys they're specialists in bird
evolution
Richard prompt at Yale as has studied
the origin of feathers and the anatomy
of feathers nothing wrong and ten dial
has done a lot with how the mechanics of
the bird wing work arrogantly
and they've been working with me over
the past year to to create a series of
lessons that I do and information
attending Wildlife Center last summer on
the evolution of
we get a super fast forward version of
that lesson here today so flight has
evolved four times in the animal kingdom
can anybody just just start spouting off
which which groups of animals have
independently well in the living fly so
fly this of all four times independently
and obviously we're here because we love
birds and so that's what you're talking
about
and when Darwin first published the
theory of evolution he didn't really
know exactly what works been into the
the tree of life birds are very strange
the only animals with feathers they also
have scales which kind of makes you
think maybe they're related to reptiles
but then they're warm-blooded which most
reptiles are warm-blooded so very
strange animal to preparing them to deal
with when coming up with well since this
time we've learned a whole lot of
evolution birds and Lextran sum it all
up all this data and what I call fuzz to
flight evolution and there are three
main lines of
evidence or opposed to playing evolution
the first thing we look at is that wings
are modified arms it's kind of hard to
imagine that when you look at a win
they're such a bizarre structure they
are modified buttons feathers are not
just for flying which is really
important because there's such complex
structures the ones that the birds use
you're blind now but that's not actually
why they had Julie involved and then
thirdly we'll take a look at the fossil
record
so wages are modified arms doesn't look
like it when you look at women but if
you take away the feathers and skin
compare them to our own arms they are
pretty much identical to ours we've got
one bone two bones wrist bones and then
what kind of look like hand bones you
notice that it is bird which is the top
obviously those those bones if you're
skeptical of those buns making them
maybe they're not only hand bones I I
sympathize with you because they look
very strange check this out this is a
chicken developing in the egg and they
start out with an early stages of
development with arms three finger arms
with claws London and those those
fingers continue to grow and common the
fused together until the guillotine
chicken wing we're also familiar with
and it's very pretty look at this
development that these are in fact
modified arms if you still don't believe
me that's okay there's more this is an
ostrich wing and ostriches actually
still have claws that grow on their
wings they only have two of them the
third ones gone but they still have the
first and second cloth pretty incredible
and then of course four years after
Darwin published his book on evolution
the origin species this creature was
discovered and described actually by one
of nerds rivals some of you who did not
accept his theory of evolution and this
is Archaeopteryx probably the most
famous fossil in the world it's it looks
very much like a dinosaur it's
definitely some sort of reptile tender
creature and when we look at it two wins
with her fully feathered we see that
that has three claws three fingers and
claws what does all this mean what does
all this data mean that bird minions are
modified arms well the really important
practical income is unfortunately
Pegasus isn't fraud
you cannot have a quadrant bed that also
has wings you can only have four now
secondly feathers are not just for
flying this airs as a bird paradise
he's using his feathers to attract a
mate the woman's like that apparently
this bee season Richard from once said
proposing that the feathers evolved for
flight is like depositing and fingers
evolved to play the piano it's just too
complex of a behavior for natural
selections who have been able to take
and form feathers just from that flight
so feathers originally involved for
something else but what what else FM is
good for ya insulation is one of the
ones that my first slide also
communication this guy is trying to
attract a mate here this bird is also
communicating but found someone backup
doesn't it's a picture thinking this
bird is using his feathers as armor and
we don't think of that as being good
armor but they're amazing armor actually
there's no dirt sand no there's no blood
in them and in this case this red-tailed
hawk is hunting around snake coaxing it
to bite its feathers of command to
arousal snake this bird is using her
feathers to collect water this is when
to bring back to the nest
she opens up her feathers to collect
that water and her her baby to drink
from her from her feathers and this
bird's doing the exact opposite closing
his feathers nice and tight stink right
so there are all sorts of reasons that
feathers basically the simple
involved Richard from studied how
feathers grow and Greta feathers start
out as little spikes that come out of
the skin and he proposed that the
original feathers actually weren't as
the spikes pass similar to what you'd
see on the back of how many more it
happens these tubular scales on their
backs and so the very first feathers
live in spikes after that we would have
these spikes that could split and open
up into these hair like structures these
suppose like structures and these what
we find still today on a lot of baby
birds including this one here and
casalinda cassowary and these are the
the simplest feather types so feathers
seem to evolve disa the basic body
covering for camouflage and protection
against new arrangement they continue to
refine and then develop new functions
the feathers on the back of this bird
paradise are they look like it looks
like a complicated mess with each each
feather is actually very simple in their
structure and we think that birds begin
to to use their feathers more for
communication and as that started to
happen in the feathers shades begin to
refine these sweats would open up into
different shapes when they opened up and
they were useful for different things
different types of communication and
then finally these communication
feathers were co-opted for flight so
they finally
towards the end of the evolution
feathers we actually have these really
complex flight feathers that develop you
can actually use for gliding and then
flying so there's there's kind of the
progression there and birds continue to
find new uses for runners who knows
where evolution will take them in the
future
lovely little parrot here so now we look
at the fun stuff the fossil record
Archaeopteryx was an incredible fossil
client because it showed us that birds
came from these reptile-like ancestors
and you know we turned up to the hands
they have teeth so they're very unlike
modern birds there's some of the
dinosaurs and they have these long
ponytails which hurts today not have
long ponytails that long better
sometimes but not long bones in their
tails but Archaeopteryx doesn't to us
where feathers feathers turn because
he's already fully feathered and so for
that we look at other theropod dinosaurs
this here is Sinosauropteryx and it's a
fuzzy little dinosaur that was found in
China recently in 1996 I believe and
it's by to be covered in fuzz here's my
recreation for Sinosauropteryx we don't
need lizards mister common spelling this
year is you Thailand and you can kind of
insisted skull and he wasn't even expert
he's closely related to t-rex and on it
is all over his body and see tiny little
feather feather elements in stone and
here we have for him he might look
something like this when he was alive
giant ham definitely human
it was alive with us and this one here
is ethene except Rick's probably my
favorite possible of all time because he
has the fuzz on his chest but on his
tail he has these beautiful display
feathers he's got four of them and the
beautiful thing that I've been except as
he predates Archaeopteryx by somewhere
between two to 18 million years so this
is an amazing specimen showing us how
feathers first of all and we do not
plant depends on his arms so it doesn't
look like you flew though there is some
evidence he might have had back tag
structures for gliding there were skin
not feathers so this is a very bizarre
animal really really fascinating Simon
thesaurus shows that he has wings like
feathers on his arms but they're still
kind of more of a fuzz and even
Velociraptor we now know because so many
of his relatives were fully feathered we
don't have another presentation on the
national Raptor skeleton but we do find
on his own on the disarmament here we
find bill moths which tell us that
Velociraptor actually was too feathered
and this is a John Conway who's an
artist out in the UK did this painting
the philosopher after bully
there he might very well have looked
when he was actually alive
mark mark Norell at the American Museum
of Natural History said if animals like
Velociraptor were allowed to their first
impression would be that they were just
like they were they were just very
beautiful looking birds just very
different so that's first flight
evolution and again what does all this
mean we see these dinosaurs developing
fuzz eventually developing flight
feathers if it looks like a duck and
quacks like a duck it's probably